hi I'm RIA and today I'm going to show
you how to make my recipe for
multi-flavored stew I could be so this
recipe was kind of assigned to me by
Alden
so he made a multi flavor sheep and pie
video and we as a team wanted to see
what else can we make multi flavor I
wanted to make something easy like I
didn't want to make each flavor from
scratch so I wanted to make one cookie
dough and a die-in defying flavors using
brown sugar is very important in order
to give the cookie that chewy texture
that I like and also using a little
white sugar helps giving a crispy
texture it's a good to combine balls
it's important to you to type of sugar
to make this american-style cookie
I feel like chocolate chip cookie it's
very unique to America I feel like this
chocolate chip cookie it's a little bit
rustic shape each individual cookie it's
a different shape and kind of I don't
know like I feel like it's imperfect but
this imperfection make it perfect we
kind of came up with simple flavor
combinations that everyone likes like
chocolate chip cookie and peanut butter
and white chocolate macadamia nuts which
is something that's underrated I think
I think it's the best multi flavor
skillet cookie recipe out there I don't
know how many out there
[Music]
I use the parchment paper to bake so I
can take it out and transport it to a
plate but if you just want to serve in a
skillet you can do so you don't need to
use the parchment paper
each cookies next to each other based on
how well their flavor profile combined
and of course everyone wants to eat the
middle part because you can whole flavor
so each of six different flavors all in
one cookie
[Music]
and also I cut it in a pea seed so you
can enjoy different flavor combinations
like chocolate chip cookie with peanut
butter cookie and white chocolate
macadamia cookie with double chocolate
cookies
I think this cookie does a good job of
capturing a lot of different characters
it's difficult to make it perfect
perfect cookie like if you have American
chocolate chip cookie kind of has a
crack and chocolate chip is sometimes
not evenly distributed it may have a den
somewhere but it's q in a way a hole
imperfection makes a great cookie
perfect it's not something you can
intend it to make it delayed but happens
that way but it's perfect in poker hey
not sure if you get it I feel like I'm
talking about cookie philosophy I don't
know I think you just try make it and
maybe you understand what I'm talking
about that's what Alex do
[Music]